like an April type of atmosphere here  that defense right there that possession  by Golden State  oh another technical that goes on eight  and he has three  pounds in this game and look at Booker  and look at Clay Thompson are continuing  to go at one another  I'm here for it people I am here for it  Miss Parker moments ago Klay Thompson  has been ejected from this ball game we  talked about him and Devin Booker  getting into it this was the double  technical between the two as Clay is  going to the bench he has words with the  official Ed Malloy who gives him his  second Technical and sends him to the  locker room but Candace as he's walking  off  it looks like he has a few Choice words  for Phoenix's been